I am hi there this is Oliver Lang crane
he's the director of photography or
cinematographer would you prefer
deepening deep short sweet yeah
DP DP it's okay old director I sake I
hope but he say scare ya that's part of
the fun we never fight though we didn't
fight the first night once yeah we got
over it very quickly good yeah
Holly offered me a beer after the first
night we were well we were both just
hungry and emotional and we were going
into the house tonight it was like I'm
gonna go get some beers do want one I
said no and then took two steps away and
I was like sorry Allie okay I will have
a beer a beer thanks
yeah and then a soft version of it yeah
what look or feel were / are you hoping
to achieve visually with your latest
project as in this project this project
nation of the press yes the one the
looker field um we did a little bit we
had a bit of a look around for the time
so obviously our film is set in 1990
about a football match come here ask
Harry and I'd like to be a little
quieter kill the kids the film is set in
1990 I'm like me and Holly were talking
about it first
yes the nostalgia thing yeah came up and
and I was 9 years old at the time and I
remembered it being a hot sunny day some
people who were a bit older I've told me
that it was actually a hot sunny day but
I think often your memory is always you
know Rosie you know Rose tinted glasses
and you and so we wanted to have that be
this this hot sunny day and this kind of
golden color yes a good time and you
described it when we first talked that
script you described it as possibly the
write the kind of start of the economic
rising in Ireland well big part of the
yoghurt
yeah when this economist in Ireland who
written about this moment being a point
that that brought confidence to the
country so people after the 1990 World
Cup in in Ireland felt more confident on
the world stage in business and and and
various places and so we had these tax
breaks and various things but suddenly
companies like IBM and Pentium and these
companies all came over and we're
setting up their European head offices
in Ireland and and you know there was
this kind of 15 years of prosperity that
came after after the 1990 World Cup 2002
and it was and the look and feel and
them visually visually it felt like it
was we looked at Martin Parr as a
referent I was photographer and his
photography is it's slightly it's like a
heightened reality used a lot of flash
outside which which isn't natural in any
way shape or form yeah
so we kind of start going down us like
me you about the you know slightly
comic-book slightly larger than life
yeah feel to costume art department it
felt bold woman it was bold in the color
choices yeah with with with the sets and
with the classic unions and the hair and
things like that you kind of you know
it's that heightened reality and but
then also there's a certain danger in
that that you can you can end up
getting getting making fun of your
characters and not believing in your
character so much we kind of wanted to
avoid that and wanted to make sure your
character looked how important with your
camera selection in achieving the look
you wanted it was an election camera
camera a choice probably for the look
maybe not as important I would say
probably our lens choice was more
important nothing
our look our lens choice and our
lighting we I'm using tungsten lights
for a kind of using tungsten lights and
warming all up so it's got a lovely soft
warm glow hopefully as opposed to you
you know you're a termite which I feel a
bit colder and bit more digital so we're
trying to give it that kind of again
period Phil and the anamorphic lenses
and some of the imperfections are the
anamorphic that bowing and the focus
banding helps to fill a little period my
camera did you use the Alexa XO what
come to you via your lecture X T what
cameras were your top three choices
there's anyway examinees Alexa what
resources did you use to research the
camera past experience from working with
different cameras there is any choice
for me I love the Alexa first
reliability and it's easy to use
like a knock here or Motorola you can
keep you might run it how much time did
you put into research yeah how you
research I was told to put into research
of the camera no Reese no time we point
to resit because I knew straight away
that's what we wanted what were the most
important factors in your final decision
based on the camera
reliability of the camera just knowing I
could achieve what I wanted to with that
camera in any kind of environment did
you consult older other filmmakers
always you're always just chatting to it
always about you yeah Oscar revived I am
therefore talking about the shot they're
figuring out things you know and you get
little bits and also just watching other
films as watching watching watching
local films we watch lots of TV from the
time as well that's where we play around
with the aspect ratio there's four three
two
it's a two three nine aspect ratio
strengths and what do you see the
strengths and weaknesses of the camera I
can't really find any wingsuits
strengths again they said there the
extra bits the zoom thing
oh the the the yeah the the the LCS the
area of LCS waste time especially zoom
gun should all be chaplaincy but the
camera love it is fantastic via rent the
camera was amazing to see you rented
from airy rental an easy decision
no 40 can afford to buy one that wasn't
gonna happen and rented a rental in
London was amazing and they helped us
out haven't amazingly yeah how much time
did you put into researching lenses we
spent a day kind of just testing a bunch
of different anamorphic lenses we cut
him had made a decision we're going out
of morphic then we spent a day going
through a few different types we had
kind of from like old like 19's crystal
crystal expresses and the old Verito
cooks and Japanese we had the Kois and
we ended up losing hope
V+ anymore fix like those because a lot
of times being your own small small
locations they're bigger bigger
Norfolk's but and so if you're working
ting handheld or you in cars they're too
big but for this we've got we've got a
lot of space but what they do give us if
they give us a really nice closed focus
interesting that you bring up that
they're too big for a car and then we
thread one through the car when we were
saying to our shop no challenge to hagel
have no car it was it seemed like a you
know that we'd maybe given herself a big
challenge to hire you at this 40 mil
lens which is basically the weight of me
after more useful and we've been running
every morning right by rental NZ's we
rented them and in the end did you
achieve the look you wanted yes I'm dead
what's your space now buck